[Music]
how better to track the return to work
and travel than through demand for doggy
daycare
rover which describes itself as airbnb
for cats and dogs
was almost brought to its knees when
covid19 hit
but as economies around the world
reopened june was a record month for
global bookings
now business is booming here's the
petcare app's chief executive
aaron easterly the pet industry in
generally is considered recession-proof
uh just because even when people skimp
in other areas they don't skimp on their
pets and pet ownership continues to go
up
and pet share wallet of household income
continues
to go up um but you know it turns out if
you're in the uh
travel related pet business and or go
into work related pet business that's
the exception to something
um it's it was not pandemic
as a ceo and entrepreneur i never
thought i'd see
negative sales but we went through a
period
last year where we had negative net
sales
meaning the cancellations from previous
bookings more than outweighed any new
bookings coming in
and i didn't even know that as a
possibility
i was like oh dear lord so it was brutal
he says demand for rovers services are a
bellwether for the economic recovery
you know the business is a pretty good
predictor
of return to normalcy um the numbers in
the us
uh the correlation um with travels
almost mind-boggling how
perfectly correlated it is the company
went public this year via a spark
to capitalize on the wave of pandemic
puppies
we saw the signs of a massive
wave of the adoption
and the new customer acquisition even
during the pandemic
and we significantly outperformed the
travel bellwethers
as the vaccine started to roll out we
saw
a wild acceleration in the business and
even stronger than we had originally
forecasted
um you know we wanted to be
appropriately capitalized uh
for this period so we decided to go
public
we decided to go public via a spec he
says people have grown more attached to
their pets during lockdowns
which will only drive demand for his
business when they're lifted
typically a doggy daycare or a dog walk
may be like hey i'm at work
for eight hours nine hours i need to
come back for a dog walk i'm gonna drop
my dog off for eight hours
and um we see some weird use cases
for doggy daycare like four o'clock to
eight pm
four pm to eight pm it's like that's not
daycare
you know it gets booked this day camera
it's not daycare um
or you know 12 to three and um
we think that's indicative of uh
the expanding use case because of
people's emotional relationship with
their animals
uh prior to the pandemic people may have
felt perfectly comfortable leaving their
animals alone for eight hours
and their animals maybe have been even
used to that um
you know like yeah like you know you
know human goes into work
uh in the morning and they come back
later and i get excited to see them
um but with people spending 24 hours a
day around their pets um
you know we think that there's some
signs that people don't feel comfortable
leaving them alone for eight hours ten
hours
so what does he see as the biggest risk
to rover and the economic recovery
i think the biggest risk is the the
vaccine roll out or vaccine hesitancy is
high
especially in some geographies or that
there is eventually a variant emerges
um that is uh more resistant to
uh the vaccines um that is the biggest
risk for the business
you